mayam biik said her years on The Big
Bang Theory were grief heavy and
complicated and her life has been just
as complicated since the show ended from
backlash over her comments about
vaccines to hosting Jeopardy and a
podcast bik's life has gone through some
big changes after achieving early
success in her career as the lead
character on Blossom mayic did something
unexpected she left the entertainment
industry to pursue a doctorate in
Neuroscience she ultimately received her
PhD in 2007 however after spending 12
years away from acting biik decided to
return because she was running out of
health insurance she told CTV I had a
toddler and a newborn and i' had been a
grad student and my insurance was
expiring this is the true story and I
figured if I can just get even a couple
jobs here or there I'll be able to get
insurance again so biic auditioned for
The Big Bang Theory with the sole goal
of acquiring health insurance through
sagaa you know I had never seen it uh I
don't watch TV so I had never seen The
Big Bang Theory despite having never
seen the show bi's Edition was
successful and she was offered the role
of Sheldon's Quirk 11 Tris Amy I I
didn't expect to be on a TV show like
that was not part of the plan at all
following my bic's debut on The Big Bang
Theory she was brought back on a per
episode basis after some time in this
unstable work situation y began to have
doubts about her longevity on the show
much to her surprise however she was
soon offered a regular contract her
colleague Jim Parsons is largely to
thank for this as he informed
showrunners that he wanted biic to be a
regular on the show he also said he
would fight for biic if he had to in
Jessica roff's book The Big Bang Theory
the definitive inside story of the Pig
hit series Parson said that was notable
for me only in that I almost never
disagreed with the writers but at some
point I felt a certain way about working
with mayam that I was like if for
whatever reason we seem to be weaning
her off of this show as a character I
would go and talk to them I can't get
you out of my heart so what I'm trying
to say is you're my heartworm upon
Landing this full-time gig B stepped
away from teaching Neuroscience piano
tutoring and living a relatively private
life as a mother in Jessica roff's book
via can admitted that when Amy first
started appearing on the show not every
viewer was on board with the idea of
Sheldon entering the dating scene yex
said there was some negative attention
when I joined the cast because some
people held Sheldon very near and dear
to them and didn't want him to change or
become a Cheesy boyfriend however as Amy
grew as a character and found her first
true friendship with Penny fans started
to gravitate toward her on Reddit one
user wrote I think Amy had the best
growth of any character on the show I
found her to be incredibly annoying in
the beginning but she grew on me because
of the depth the writers gave her Amy
went from a wilting Wallflower to a
vibrant sunflower and she will always be
one of my favorites her work on screen
not only resonated with audiences but
also earned biic her first Emmy
nomination in 2012 this was followed by
three more nominations over the next
three consecutive years in 2013 May and
bik's personal life experienced a major
upheaval when she and Michael Stone
divorced after 10 years of marriage for
bolik the end of her marriage also
brought up difficult emotions while she
was filming the season 11 finale in
which Amy and Sheldon tie the KN Amy may
have been bursting with excitement but
behind the scenes biic was uncomfortable
I tried to be married once like I was in
that position and I failed despite these
feelings biik still went through with
the episode and it's possible her
onscreen marriage helped beic moved past
her sense of failure because a few years
later she began dating her current
boyfriend Jonathan Cohan though Mayan
biic had no idea what she was getting
into when she auditioned for the part of
Amy on The Big Bang Theory she found a
home on the Warner Brother set so when
it came to time for the show to end she
struggled to accept it in a February
2019 grock Nation blog post fik
explained how she experienced the five
stages of grief as The Big Bang Theory
approached its conclusion at first biic
feared what her life would look like
moving forward she was also saddened by
the fact that she'd likely lose touch
with many casts and crew members after
spending countless hours together but in
the end the actor acknowledged that she
couldn't change things and learned to
embrace whatever the future held for her
in redl's book be admitted life is
enormous and my life in the years on The
Big Bang Theory were some of the most
grief heavy complicated years for me
personally it was kind of like okay what
next that had to be my attitude and it
still is I would have been happy to be
there until people weren't watching
anymore it didn't take long for my biic
to return to television 2 years after
the Big Bang Theory wrapped up she began
executive producing and starring in the
sitcom call me Cat in many ways cat is
very similar to Amy when audiences meet
her in season 1 she's single in trying
to forge her own path in life ultimately
Breaking Free from her mother's
expectations call me cat ran for 3 years
but abruptly came to an end in May 2 23
after a decline in ratings in a
Sentimental Instagram post biik wrote
it's so hard to say goodbye to yesterday
we made a lot of people laughter in Co
in ways that at first seemed impossible
but with this incredible cast all things
that seemed impossible became possible
it's only natural that given their
status as the stars of a major
television show like The Big Bang Theory
the public would be curious about the
cast personal lives however being in the
spotlight comes with its challenges
which mayic understands all too well
over the years her opinion about certain
topics especially vaccines have received
a lot of backlash in 2009 she revealed
that she hadn't vaccinated her two
children after conducting research and
having discussions with their
pediatrician more recently bi said her
kids are now vaccinated but don't have
as many as the average American child
her commentary on other matters also
landed her in hot water these included
her remarks that powerful
ill-intentioned men like Harvey
Weinstein overlooked her because her
appearance didn't represent the standard
for beauty in Hollywood theic later
issued an apology for the comment
claiming she never meant to make
Weinstein's victims feel as if they
brought his actions on themselves due to
their looks the actor wrote on X
formerly known as Twitter you were never
responsible for being assaulted I truly
sorry for causing so much pain and I
hope you can all forgive me as the Big
Bang Theory came to an end my biic
feared she'd lose touch with her onset
friends and colleagues however bik has
managed to stay connected with her
former co-stars for example Jim Parsons
was the reason she landed the lead role
on call me cat on The Ellen degenerous
Show y revealed that Parsons informed
her that his production company was
adapting Miranda the British show call
me cat is based on for American
television at first bi thought he was
simply informing her about his latest
Endeavor she told Ellen I said well Jim
that seems like a really awesome project
good luck you've got my vote of
confidence and he said no I'm asking
because I want you to be in it I was
shocked because I think I'm very
annoying but however annoying I am he
obviously still wanted to work with me
to get to produce with him and and get
to know his whole team it's it's been
really really special on The Big Bang
Theory Amy is the one trying to push her
physical relationship with Sheldon along
however she has no experience when it
comes to intimacy since she's been
sheltered by her mother Amy is a late
bloomer when it comes to these things on
her grock Nation blog bi would often
discuss the topics Amy was experiencing
on the show including Notions of modesty
boundaries and more and over time her
writing caught the eye of the publisher
of Penguin Books theic was asked to
write more about the female experience
as a whole and penned gring up how to be
strong smart and spectacular the book
released in 2019 boasts a 4.5 rating on
Amazon and has been a hit with readers
one Amazon reviewer wrote this book is
perfect for you and your daughter or any
female who may need some guidance which
we all do she does such a good job
putting it all into a non-judgmental
perspective another reviewer wrote the
author is a mother but her voice in the
book is more of a mentor a mentor who
wants the very best for the reader
however they do warn that some of the
content might be too mature for pre-teen
following the death of longtime Jeopardy
host Alex tbec biik and legendary
contestant Ken Jennings began
alternating as the show's hosts it was a
new environment for bi and audiences
certainly took notice ever since
accepting the Jeopardy gig biic has
received a lot of negative feedback from
viewers with the main point of criticism
being how she moves the game along one
Jeopardy fan wrote on Reddit it's her
Rhythm it gets in the way of the game as
it's been said by a few people Ken knows
the answer mayam needs to check whether
the answer is right or not but it's not
just the answers the way she conducts
the game is just halting in a way that
Ken is smooth another Reddit user said
their biggest pet peeve is the long
pause biic takes before telling a
contestant that is correct meanwhile
another Reddit user feels bolic is
better suited toward special editions of
the show such as Celebrity Jeopardy but
according to Michael davies's executive
producer of Jeopardy there isn't a
decrease in ratings when biic takes over
from Jenning he told vulture when Ken is
hosting and mayam is hosting there's
zero difference it's exactly the same
and that's the broadest part of the
audience in 2023 biik was nominated for
Nei for outstanding host for a game show
so it means she's doing something right
in the midst of her ongoing television
career May Bic hosts the podcast May
bic's breakdown on the podcast B
discusses various topics surrounding
mental health with an array of guests
including her old Big Bang Theory
co-stars Melissa Rous and Simon hellberg
in each conversation both serious and
hilarious aspects of their lives are
revealed hellberg is candid about his
mental health struggles while Rous a
massive Blossom fan recalls trying to be
cool the first time she was in bi's
presence every episode is co-hosted by
be's boyfriend Jonathan Cohen who helped
her launch the podcast in the throws of
the pandemic bi told Forbes my partner
Jonathan and I have a shared passion for
mental illness and mental illness
education so we decided to start a
podcast the idea is to explore all the
aspects of mental health that many of us
are not told about yic may have been
anxious about what life would look like
after the Big Bang Theory but so far
things are going pretty well she's
acting and directing all while shining a
light on how mental health battles don't
[Music]
descriminate